behind tight security this
is the nerve center of south korea's
successful covid response
a test and trace system that actually
works
sky news was given exclusive access to
the closely guarded programme
lee jin is an epidemiological
investigator a poirot of the pandemic
putting together all sorts of data to
understand how covid is spreading
through the population
when someone tests positive for kovid 19
in south korea their information is
uploaded into this system
which is up and running back on april
the first battleground
investigators interview the patient to
identify their travel history
but they also pull in reams of data
including credit card transactions and
mobile phone location history
you
that produces a transmission network of
contacts for each positive covert case
a hundred close contacts are tested
officials say
in the uk tracers now only identify two
contacts per case but south korea is
willing to help the british government
if it asks
that system has helped south korea
record just over 500 covert deaths
during the whole pandemic
unlike countries like taiwan and new
zealand it has not been able to
effectively eliminate the disease
instead it's been dealing with rolling
clusters
one of those was centered around a
highly secretive and controversial
church
responsible for a fifth of the whole
country's covert infections
today its members recovered patients are
donating plasma to help produce
treatments
was accused of obstructing contact
traces and its founder has been charged
with hiding
information an allegation the church
denies
illness can be turned into treatment
mistakes
can become wisdom as the uk prepares for
life
after the second lockdown it could do
worse than learn from south korea
tom cheshire sky news